[Music]
welcome back
so i am incredibly excited today to tell
you about partial differential equations
and so in this video what i'm going to
do is essentially motivate what are
partial differential equations
why do we need to solve them and i'm
going to give you a lot of examples of
types of pdes that come up
throughout physics and engineering and
science okay so this is absolutely one
of my favorite topics um and i gotta say
i am just so
grateful to have the opportunity to
teach this to you it's something that
has
you know partial differential equations
have changed my life you know it allows
you to solve problems
that uh you can't solve without them and
so i really really hope that this is
kind of opens a door to you like it did
for me okay calculus is kind of the same
way it's one of those things that once
you see the world through that lens you
can't unsee it
okay so a partial differential equation
there's a definition here it's
essentially a set of equations
in terms of a multivariate function
and its partial derivatives
and so the multivariate function um
the multivariate function u that i'm
going to talk about u
is often a function of space
and time okay so this is my function
um
x is space
and t is time
and this might be a this might be a
scalar function this might be the
temperature distribution
on this piece of glass here so x would
be a two dimensional x and y vector
so in general this could be a vector u
could be a vector
and t could be time or you could be a
scalar like this could be the
temperature distribution like i said
this could be the fluid flow vector
field of the error in this room in which
case you would have three components
the x velocity u the y velocity v and
the z velocity w
and x would be a three-dimensional space
vector x y and z
so this is a very flexible
function it's a function of space and
time typically
and the partial differential equation is
going to relate this function and its
partial derivatives so a good example
would be the wave equation so i could
say
the second partial derivative of u
with respect to time
is equal
to some constant uh some some positive
constant
times the second partial derivative
of u with respect to x
so in this case u is a scalar function
this is just a scalar function
and x is a scalar you know position
along the x-axis
and this would be the equation for a
wave
uh you know kind of a wave
u
of x and t propagating
at some constant velocity c
okay
and i'm going to you know we can derive
this we can analyze this this is just
one example of what a partial
differential equation looks like
so again it is a
relationship between some function u and
its partial derivatives here i have a
partial derivative and t and a partial
derivative and x
now that's different than an ordinary
differential equation so um
you know if i looked at my ode this is
just a sidebar if i look at an ordinary
differential equation
it is usually a single derivative
of a function you know x of t
equals some
uh you know function of x like lambda
x of t
and in this case there is only one
variable that's being varied time so i
have a
an independent variable time a dependent
variable x and i'm just taking
derivatives only with respect to that
independent variable time
whereas for partial differential
equations it has multivariate
dependencies it's a function of multiple
variables x and time in this case or
maybe even multiple spatial dimensions
and so i have to think about partial
derivatives with respect to each of
those
those independent variables
okay good
uh so that is just kind of an example or
a definition of what a pde is and this
is an example what i want to do is i
want to start building up some of the
most useful pdes that we use like all
the time in physics and engineering and
science and then we're going to start
thinking about what are some of those
properties of those pdes that are
particularly useful
so maybe one of the things i'll start
with is i'll just kind of describe some
of the
canonical
canonical pdes
and all of these canonical pdes that i'm
going to describe have some common
properties
so they are going to be linear
and i'm going to define what i mean in a
minute so they're linear
they are second order
and they are what is known as
homogeneous or homogeneous depending on
homogeneous
okay so i'm going to define what each of
these means
so linear just means that um
the partial
differential equation can be written in
terms of linear operators where there's
no nonlinear terms like u squareds or u
times u sub x and things like that let
me make a quick quick quick sidebar
that oftentimes we use subscripts like u
sub t
to denote partial u
partial t
and things like u sub x or u sub x x
would equal the second partial
derivative of u with respect to x
squared okay so often times partial
derivatives are denoted by subscripts
and i'm going to do the same thing here
so linear basically means that there are
no nonlinear terms there's no things
like no
[Music]
no products or cross products no
products
between
my various u
u sub x u sub x x terms so i don't have
any u squareds or u times u x's or u x
times u x x's those would be non-linear
and i'm going to talk actually about
linear more later so just to remember
that
second order means that there's no more
than a second no derivatives higher than
second order no derivatives
higher
than second
order okay
so
you know i could technically have
a fourth derivative and x a fourth order
diffusion term there are physical
systems that have fourth order diffusion
uh but at least in these canonical pdes
i'm going to write down here we're only
going to think about second order pdes
and uh homogeneous means that there is
no time forcing or spatial forcing so
the the governing rules of the system
are the same throughout time and they're
the same throughout space
now for example in this wave equation
this is essentially the equation for a
guitar string okay
and you could imagine
building a guitar string where the first
half of it is nylon and the second half
of it is steel
and in that case that will be a
non-homogeneous
differential equation because the the
rules of the equation will change on
those different halves of the guitar
string because the material properties
will mean that the c is different in one
part of space than in another part of
space
so what homogeneous means
is that there is no
um
time dependent forcing or spatial
dependent forcing no
time
dependent forcing
or space
dependent forcing
and you know now that i'm thinking about
it that example i gave you is actually
not a good example
of an inhomogeneous equation so i can
have an equation where the constants
themselves are functions of space
um
you know that that's okay but i guess uh
here what i mean is if i actually
actively force my system in time or in
space if i have some plus forcing
function that's a forcing of time and
space and i'll give you lots of
equations examples of this for example
in the heat equation if i have a blow
torch and i'm you know actively heating
up a metal plate that would be an
inhomogeneous term in that equation so
we'll we'll talk through all of this in
a minute
but these are the three kind of basic
properties for these canonical pdes i'm
going to write down now
and so i want to write down
three basic partial differential
equations we have
we have the wave equation
which i've actually already
written down before
we have
the heat equation this is one of the
most important equations in all of
physics the heat
equation
and we've already seen before when we
looked at potential flow we have
laplace's equation
laplace's equation and laplace's
equation and heat equation are very very
closely related
so here what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to write these down
and then we're going to talk about what
their properties are we're going to
confirm that they're linear second order
homogeneous equations
so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to write it down in
kind of a specific form for two
independent variables
so the wave equation is u sub t t
equals a positive constant c squared u
sub x x
that's actually exactly what i wrote
down here just using subscript notation
and this is for a one dimensional wave
equation i have two independent
variables i have time and one spatial
coordinate x okay so this is a 2d
version
the heat equation is another super
important equation so this one again for
for a simple case
is u sub t a single time derivative a
single time derivative of u
equals another positive constant we're
going to call this alpha squared
times u sub x x
now
these look extremely close to each other
[Music]
all that not
i pluck it you know i available these
these standing waves or if i take a a
rope and i whip the rope it will send
this traveling wave traveling along that
rope and the shape will kind of remain
constant
whereas for the heat equation if i have
some temperature distribution
in a one-dimensional piece of metal
immediately it's going to start to
diffuse and average out until it all
becomes a constant temperature which is
very very very different behavior just
because of the single additional partial
derivative in this wave equation
okay
and the the third canonical pde that we
always study uh in physics
is laplace's equation
which is just
the
heat equation if i set u t equal to zero
it's the steady state heat distribution
uh like let's say i have a metal plate
and i heat one side you know in a hot
bath and one side in a cold bath and i
insulate the other two sides there will
be a steady state temperature
distribution that is given by laplace's
equation so again i'm going to write
this in two dimensions
as
u sub x x
plus u sub y y
equals zero
now notice i'm actually writing this in
two dimensions this has two so so
there's no time in laplace's equation
because it's for steady state heat
distribution
and so this would be how the the steady
state heat distribution has to satisfy
this
for a two-dimensional uh heated object
for example with boundary conditions
and again we already saw that
you know we already saw this from the
potential flow equations also solutions
of laplace's equation
are potentials that we can use for
potential flows
good so these are three canonical pd's i
also want to show you what this looks
like in vector calculus notation for
arbitrary dimensions because i think
you know we've been essentially building
up partial differential equations like
laplace's equation using vector calculus
div grad and curl and so i want to show
you what this looks like
for those cases as well
okay good
um
so the wave equation in nd is going to
look like u uh u sub t t
equals again some positive constant
now times the laplacian
of u okay and uh this is going to be so
if u is a function of x y and z
this is now you know second partial of u
with respect to x squared plus second
partial of u with respect to y squared
plus second partial of u with respect to
z squared and you could in fact write
down an n dimensional a 10 dimensional
laplacian operator if you like it's easy
same thing for the heat equation it's
just u sub t equals a positive constant
alpha squared again times the laplacian
operator of u
and laplace's equation aptly named is
just the laplacian operator of u
del squared u
set equal to zero
and so these are kind of the n
dimensional this this would give you the
steady state heat distribution not just
in a two-dimensional plate but in a
three-dimensional object then you take
the three-dimensional laplacian
or an n-dimensional object sometimes
for example in machine learning you
might add some kind of artificial
diffusion on an n-dimensional vector and
you would need to be looking at an
n-dimensional laplace's equation
now there are more complicated pdes that
we use in our daily lives like the navy
or stokes equations are non-linear
equations okay so they are they don't
satisfy this kind of nice property that
the solutions uh satisfy superposition
there's other equations that are you
know not second order like i mentioned
that if you had u quadruple x there are
systems that have that kind of fourth
order diffusion
i can have systems that are
inhomogeneous i'm forcing them in space
or in time okay actively forcing those
systems and so we can essentially relax
all of these but these are the canonical
building block partial differential
equations that we use to build intuition
to understand solution techniques and so
we'll actually spend a lot of time
thinking about how do you solve
laplace's equation in fact we can derive
separation of variables one of the most
powerful techniques to solve pdes we can
demonstrate it on laplace's equation and
then use it to solve the heat equation
you can use the fourier transform
techniques to solve the wave equation
and so these all become very very useful
uh as kind of building blocks to
understand how partial differential
equations work
good are there other things i want to
tell you i'm sure there are in fact i
think i'm going to tell you lots more in
other videos
maybe one of the things i'll mention is
what does it mean to be a linear pde so
we've talked a lot about this for
ordinary differential equations we know
that we like linear ordinary
differential equations specifically
because it means that linear
superposition holds if i have two
solutions
of a linear differential equation and i
add up that solution it is still a
solution and that also is what linear
means for for pdes so let me just write
this out um
so linear
is just a way of saying
that
superposition holds superposition
holds
and so what that means let's take the
wave equation for example
if i have two solutions of the wave
equation i have two waves that are
traveling at some constant speed i've
got two solutions u1 and u2
and i add that solution up i superimpose
that solution it will also be the
solution of the wave equation because
this is a linear partial differential
equation
and in fact like i mentioned all three
of these equations are linear that is
super super useful so laplace's equation
tells me what the you know you know
gravitational potential or the electric
potential is going to be in a medium
away from charge densities or point
masses
and again because linear superposition
holds i can have 10 charges and just add
up the fields from all of those charges
to figure out what
the field is going to be at some distant
location x
linear superposition is one of the most
powerful tools we have in all of
mathematics to handle differential
equations i'm going to say it again
when we say superposition holds
this means
if
u1
and u2
are solutions
to pde
then in fact any constant alpha u1 plus
beta u2
also
a solution
and so that allows us to essentially
cook up basis solutions or eigen
solutions and then take linear
combinations of those for more
complicated problems for more
complicated boundary conditions
geometries etc etc
and in fact that's how fourier analysis
was invented the like fourier himself
kind of invented this fourier transform
specifically
to provide a basis of kind of eigen
solutions for the heat equation
so the heat equation
you can essentially
transform this into some diagonalized
system using these sines and cosines
these fourier transform that fourier
invented and it simplifies the heat
equation and it provides a family of
unique orthogonal basis solutions so
that any combination of them also
satisfies the heat equation
really really powerful stuff so we'll
talk about you know all of this more
but i really really just love this idea
that you know linearity allows you to
add up uh independent solutions of these
equations and there's still a solution
and linearity also relates to the
operators themselves so remember we're
talking about um
this is
an operator this laplacian operator
you know del squared is equal to
the divergence of the gradient of
you know whatever function so if i have
the laplacian of f
it's equal to the divergence of the
gradient of f for some scalar value to f
and
essentially
these the gradient and the divergence
operator and therefore the laplacian
operator are linear operators the
partial derivative of a function u is a
linear operator on u
and so that's something i really want to
to convey to you this is a kind of an
abstract concept but very important is
that
i'm just going to give you some examples
of linear operators so
a linear operator on u one example would
be if i just multiply it by a constant
if i take u times 5u
that's a linear operator
and you can verify this because you can
plug in u1 plus u2 and that's still
equal to 5u1 plus 5u2 it's the linear
operator of u1 plus the linear operator
of u2 so it's linear
another linear operator and this is
really important and i want you to
verify this this is extremely important
is the partial derivative of u with
respect to x
in fact the partial derivative of u with
respect to any of its uh the variables
it depends on partial u partial t
partial u partial x second derivative of
u with respect to x the laplacian of u
the gradient the divergence you know all
of these are linear operators
and so i want you to actually verify
that uh this l
of you know alpha
u1
plus
beta
u2 right so if if u1 and u2 are
solutions then i want you to plug in
this
and confirm that this is alpha
times the operator of u1
plus beta times
the operator
okay this thing is kind of a pain to
erase
uh plus beta
times the operator
of u2 and i'm just going to say this
again
so what linearity means
is that if u1 and u2 are solutions
to the pde then alpha u1 plus beta u2 is
also a solution
and what that means for a linear
operator we build up this pde using
these linear operators this is a linear
operator on u this is a linear operator
on you multiplying by c squared is a
linear operator on u this is all kind of
l of u equals zero a linear operator of
u equals another linear operator of u
and so to confirm that an operator like
a partial derivative is in fact linear
we verify that if we take two
functions u1 and u2 and we add them up
in some combination a plus b
then we hit that with the operator
you can essentially you know pop the
operator out you can pop these constants
out and you can split the sum
so that it is equal to that constant a
times the linear operator of u1 plus
that constant beta times the linear
operator of u2
and i'm gonna have you like get a piece
of paper actually verify this is true
for partial u partial x verify it's true
for second derivative of u with respect
to x or for the laplacian of u with
respect to
a multivariate function of let's say x
and y
really really really important okay and
these are all linear pdes
maybe the last thing i want to show you
before you know we'll talk more about
pdes a lot in the next few lectures so i
don't want to overload you here
but maybe what i will do
for the last thing is just give you an
example of a non-linear so this is not
going to be a canonical pde it's a
non-linear pde
and this non-linear pde
is going to be berger's equation so
burgers
burgers
equation it sounds delicious i'm quite
hungry
so this is kind of a non-linear
burgers equation and i'm just going to
write out what this pde is and then
we'll talk about why it's non-linear
okay
so the partial differential equation for
burgers equation in one component is the
time derivative u sub t
plus u u x
equals some viscosity uh u x x
so again this is for the one-dimensional
burgers equation this u is just a
function of time and a single spatial
variable x
and it also is going to be describing
how waves propagate uh in space and time
but because we have
this non-linear term here this is a
product
this is a product of u and u x this is
not linear you can try to do this
for u u x and this is not true so that's
another thing i'd really like you to
verify that this is non-linear
and it's called a nonlinear
uh convection
okay that's a really important term here
and we'll talk about burger's equation
and the physics more later
but i also want to point out in vector
form you can write this as a vector
u sub t this is for a higher dimensional
burgers equation
plus u dot
grad of u
plus my
sorry equals i i
have to erase twice in one video okay
good
this equals my laplacian operator my new
times laplacian of u and i'm going to
say that this is for a vector valued u
so now u could be
the velocity in the x and the y
component so this u could be
u equals you know u in the x direction
and v in the y direction
and it's a function of x and y and t so
now i have to use these partial these
kind of
gradient and laplacian operators to
account for those those partial
derivatives
okay good so let's just take a step back
and do a quick summary uh to wrap up
so partial differential equations
like ordinary differential equations
like calculus is one of the most
powerful tools we have to describe
systems that change in space and time
the world around us changes in space and
time so your brain has you know it's
changing as a function of x and t
constantly the atmosphere the climate is
changing as a function of space and time
the ocean is moving and flowing as a
space function of space and time
and this partial differential equation
framework allows us to relate that
function we care about and how it
changes in space and time through these
relationships of partial derivatives
generally speaking we want to solve for
this unknown function u we want to solve
this equation for u that's usually the
goal
and that is typically easier to do for
these linear pdes because if we can
solve for kind of a basis of solutions
then linear combinations of those
solutions also are solutions uh but
there's a lot of interesting equations
like this burgers equation is basically
uh kind of a 1d analog of the navy or
stokes equations
and so you know for really nonlinear
fluid flows it you're not going to have
that linear superposition and we're
going to have to have other other
solution techniques
okay a lot more on this coming soon stay
tuned thank you